Vatican City: The capital of the Catholic Church, in addition to being the home of the Pope, also brings many magnificent art and history to the world.
Collected among the countries with the smallest borders in the world:
It's even small enough to walk around its border in 40 minutes.
How is this small country that can't be smaller?
The short answer is: because Mussolini, and the long answer is extremely complicated,
So I will give you a simplified medium length answer now:
The Pope ruled a country called the Papal State long ago, and its territory was covered at the time.
Currently part of Italy. It was under this rule of a thousand years that the Popes built the largest church in existence.
St. Peter's Basilica -- and the mountain where the main hall is located, called the Vatican Hill
A wall was built around the mountain base.
However, the Italian kingdom around the Papal State believes that the Roman city will be a kingdom for their kingdom.
Awesome capital, so the kingdom was destroyed.
The pope, who was destroyed, hid in the walls of the Vatican Mountains and contradicted contradictoryly.
The existence of the Italian kingdom, and at the same time complaining about becoming
The prisoner of the Kingdom of Italy - but he just finished saying that the country does not exist.
The Italian king, who did not intend to eradicate the Pope and risked a religious civil war, decided to wait for the Pope to come out himself.
And think that the Pope will give up sooner or later -- but if religion is so easy to yield, it is not religion.
-- After 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 and 60 years, the situation has not changed.
And this led us to Benito Mussolini, the then Italian Prime Minister.
And the Pope kept complaining to Italian Catholics about their self-imposed imprisonment,
Therefore, Mussolini wanted to add points to his achievements in this matter, so he reached the following agreement with the Pope at that time:
a) Italy gave the Vatican’s territory to the Pope;
with...
b) Italy gave the Pope a lot of compensation.
In return
a) The Pope recognizes the existence of Italy;
with...
b) The Pope promises to remain neutral in politics and war.
Because Mussolini is afraid, this may cause some troubles.
After the agreement was signed, a new country, the Vatican City, was born.
Today, this mini country on the mountain has everything you expect to see in the country:
She has a government that sets her own laws and enforces the law by her own police.
And imprisoned those who violated their laws in their own prisons.
She has her own bank, prints her own stamps, and issues her own license plate.
But only her citizens can drive in her territory, probably because they are terrible
Parking 埸--but like many self-respecting countries: she has her own
Unique top-level domain name: .VA
But even with the symbols of these countries, the Vatican City is very different from other countries.
Take your beautiful hat, because it will become more and more strange next:
To understand the Vatican City, you must first understand two kinds of people and things:
The famous Pope, the fascinating Holy See, the Vatican City itself and
The Vatican City King, who was basically unknown to her.
The first is the Pope: he has a throne to sit on and become a Roman city on the throne.
Bishop of all Catholics
In fact, all Catholic bishops have their own thrones but because
The bishop of Rome is the Pope, so he has a special throne and has its unique name: the Holy Land.
Every time the Pope dies or retirees, there will be a throne power game and decide which one
The bishop can then enter the Holy See.
So although the bishop came and went, the Holy See is eternal. So the name of the Holy See is not just
The throne, but also refers to all the rules that make the Catholic Church a Catholic court.
In the case of Mussolini’s previous agreement, he technically took the Vatican’s territory.
To the Holy See - and, believe it or not, it is a regular legal person in international law.
Basically, every time you hear the word of the Holy See, you think of it as a Catholic company.
The Pope is the chairman.
Now let's talk back to the king. The Vatican City King is within the border of the Vatican City
Have absolute, uncontrollable power and his presence makes the Vatican City one of the only six absolute monarchies in the world.
These include Brunei, Oman, Qatar, Saudi Arabia and Swaziland.
The absolute power of his king is why the Vatican City cannot join the European Union because only
Only a democratic country can join.
Although the Vatican City, strictly speaking, has a legislature -- by the Pope
The appointed cardinal composition - but the Vatican City King, can reject his decision at any time for any reason.
But why have you never heard of a king in the Vatican City? Because although the king and the pope
Are two different characters, but they happen to be the same person at the same time.
And thus caused a wonderful phenomenon: because the pope was elected and the king
They have absolute power but they are the same person, thus making the Vatican City the only election-determined, non-hereditary
Absolute monarchy.
It is this dual identity that makes it difficult to solve the mystery of the Vatican City because of the Pope.
As the situation changes, it can be the king of the Vatican City or
The Pope of the Holy See.
do you understand? do not understand? Ok, let me make a metaphor:
Imagine an international organization with a lot of power, called Grey Industry, and a chairman.
He persuaded the United States to give one of its islands to the industry, and it turned the island into
A new country -- the Grey city -- is made by the absolute monarch as its government, while
Set up a constitution to define the king of Grey City for the chairman of the Grey industry.
Obviously, he should now move his industrial headquarters to
This new country -- and the industry benefits from the laws of the country
Internationality can also benefit the country. And as a middleman sometimes do
The chairman is better; sometimes it is better to be a king.
This is exactly the same as in the Vatican City.
But if you still feel confused, don't worry, because even other countries have analyzed it in a mess.
For example, the United Nations has a legal person as a member of the Holy See - but there is no
The Vatican City itself is a country. And the passport issued by the church to the citizens of the Vatican City
Although it is issued from a company, not a country, it is accepted by other countries.
And when it comes to the citizens of the Vatican City, they may be because of the Pope’s religious leaders and the king’s
The strange result caused by the dual identity.
Although other countries produce new citizens through famous human reproduction,
But the Vatican City is not like this. No one in the Vatican City is a native of the public - and that is not because
Under the rounding, there is no female citizen there.
To become a citizen in the city, you must ask the king to designate you as a citizen.
The king will only designate you as a citizen if you work for the Pope and at the same time.
And because of the absolute power of the king, your national identity is completely under his control. If you quit as the Pope
The service work, the king -- and also the pope -- will abolish your national identity.
These rules make the Vatican City not a permanent permanent resident:
There are only 500 citizens there - even less than a few in a few countries
The number of people living in the skyscrapers - and these citizens act as cardinals,
Diplomats, Pope's bodyguards or other Catholic-related work, etc.
So the best analogy for the Vatican City is a corporate headquarters with sovereign independence.
And give their staff temporary citizenship; not a real city-state like Singapore:
Because it has a self-propagating population and participates in a series of economic activities.
And the Vatican City has nothing.
But in the end, the reason why the world cares about the Vatican City is not because of its citizens in its walls.
It is because of the billions of Catholics outside the city wall.